major sin and in Islamic Sharia they
will get lashed 80 times
Brothers and sisters, this is the winter
season in the UK. Today in my house my
boiler broke and the house was freezing
cold. My kids are wearing jackets. I'm
trying to find heating and as a father
I'm trying to make sure my kids and my
wife are warm. Imagine people around the
world. I'm working with One Ummah
brothers and sisters 100% donation
policy charity who are helping Syria,
Lebanon and Afghanistan. People who are
freezing to death in tents brothers and
sisters. Donate whatever you can because
today's experience with me showed me
subhanallah how vulnerable we are and
just made me remember those people who
are in need. Whatever you donate guys,
even if it is £1, help those people in
those countries. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
are well inshallah. I came across this
video. I'm sure you guys have seen it.
If you haven't seen it, we'll watch it
for ourselves in a minute inshallah. Of
a
a potential male and a female both
driving recklessly which you'll see the
video inshallah in a minute and then
getting into an accident. Now that's all
well and, you know, bad. I'm not going
to say it's well and good. It's well and
bad. But then something happens which
takes it to another level where I just
believe this is a video reminder to the
brother and to the sister and the the
man that she was in the car with. We
assume that it's a family member. That's
as a believer we need to assume the
best. Um but yeah, let's watch it for
ourselves. Firstly, this is a video clip
of how recklessly they were driving and
I think this brother who was upset about
it maybe they tried to cut him off etc.
He got really annoyed. Here's the video
clip. Let's just come back.
Brothers, guys, look at that guys.
Guys
I should
Look.
Airbags going off, everything's going
off.
Look.
for yourself. Obviously if I was driving
that I'd be very upset
and the way they're driving etc. is
recklessly. They can kill somebody.
People die. People die. Innocent people
die. Innocent people's children die
because of reckless driving. That's
number one. Number two, what happens is
then this they they get into an
accident. This brother, I think he's a
Bengali brother, he parks up and then he
heads towards that direction of the
accident. And here is what happens.
Here's the altercation and then we can
talk about
what he said and what he should have not
said and how he should have reacted.
Here's the video inshallah. Your man's
having laughing gas.
YOUR MAN'S HAVING LAUGHING GAS. WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO TO HER?
YOUR MAN'S HAVING LAUGHING GAS. YOUR
[__] MAN
YOUR [__] MAN IS HAVING LAUGHING GAS.
SHE'S HAVING LAUGHING GAS. YOU DON'T
SKIT.
[__] SKIT. WATCH ME I'M GOING TO MAKE
YOU FAMOUS ON TIKTOK. WATCH. THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE LAUGHING GAS
ON EID DAY, YEAH?
LOOK.
[__] put you right away. Couldn't
catch up to him.
[__] put you.
Brothers, guys, look at that guys.
Guys
I should
Look.
Airbags going off, everything's going
off.
Should I get you a right off? Should I
get you a RIGHT OFF
PLEASE?
FOLLOW UP FROM LAST NIGHT'S EVENTS. I'VE
JUST found out that it wasn't the girl
that was having
laughing gas. It was actually the
driver. It was the driver's fault and
obviously and I've, you know, recorded
the girl and obviously and I've uploaded
it on socials which I shouldn't have and
obviously I feel
very, you know,
ashamed of what I said to her yesterday
and everything. Obviously it was all out
of anger. I shouldn't have said it and
like I said I'm going to say it again.
It was the driver. The driver had it. So
guys, you saw that for yourselves
subhanallah. I mean look, you can be
upset. You can be annoyed and these
things look, it costs people's lives,
yeah? So I'm assuming that's the reason
the brother was upset. However, you're
walking towards the direction of the
accident. Number one, you don't know
what happened. Number two, you are
there's a sister that's coming your
direction. She could have been in the
back of the car. As far as I know you
know she wasn't driving the car. Yes,
she could be to blame. I don't want to,
you know, always,
you know, sadly sometimes sisters
females don't like blaming females. It
says of course she's there. Why is she
in the car? And there is a laughing gas.
When he goes to the car, there's a
laughing gas. Now I don't know how he
knows because before the accident,
before he even approached the car, he
was like oh your man is taking laughing
gas. And then he goes and calls a her a
skit, yeah? Which we know what it means.
It means hoe. In Bengali they call it
magi, yeah? So this is actually very
vile. Why? Because at the end of the day
you can be upset. No matter how upset
you We even know from the process of the
hadith that even when a loved one dies
that one should be patient and not say
things that can cross the boundaries of
Allah of oh Allah why did you do this to
me? Oh Allah And Allah subhanallah Allah
subhanallah protect us from going
crossing those boundaries. So number one
is a major sin and in Islamic Sharia
they will get lashed 80 times for
calling her that skit. The word skit.
Yes, you have no right to call her skit.
Yeah, no matter what happened in that
instance you cannot go on calling You
can say oh you stupid or you're an
idiot. You're careless. You did that.
Whatever it can be. Even those words
will be like okay, you know, can be
considered backbiting. We can say but to
call a woman the word skit one of the
seven major sins. One of them is to call
a chased woman that she's a skit or
she's this etc. I even feel
uncomfortable repeating it but I'm just
trying to give context here. Okay, she's
a Muslim woman. She's an honorable woman
in our eyes. And even the guy was who
said oh that's oh your man your man. How
do you know it's a man? How do you know
it's not a cousin, her uncle, her her
brother?
Why man? How do you know it's a man? So
brother, I realized today that the
brother who's filming this told me that
you've done apology video and I just saw
it today. So
may Allah subhanallah accept the
apology. And know that you have to
repent for your statement as well
because you what you said against was
wrong. Now coming to the whole picture.
Our my dear sister who was in that car
and your family member. I'm going to
assume the best that that's your family
member who's in the car etc. yeah? Okay,
I'm not going to go and assume that it's
your boyfriend or etc. I would have been
like no. You're a Muslim woman and as
our duty to protect your honor and
dignity.
So now watching that subhanallah it just
makes me sad. I don't know if he was
taking the laughing gas or not and again
I'm going to assume the best he wasn't.
It was there for whatever reason. We
have to assume the best. Obviously you
can't be stupid at the same time as
well. There are many Muslim youth. We
know last year
accidents happened. People die. They
lose loved ones. Imagine standing in
front of Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala,
the one who provides, protects, makes
your heart beat, looks after you, does
everything for you and you're going to
be disobedient disobedient to him in
every shape or form and then you're
taking drugs and you're taking these
things that make you high and you're
going to stand on yawm al-qiyamah
high. You know
Believe me, on yawm al-qiyamah you are
not going to be there and it's not going
to be because of the drugs' effect.
Wallahi, on that day Allah subhanallah
wa ta'ala tells us that the brother will
not know their family members. Yes, your
mother and father are not going to know
you. That day so much so that the
Prophet when Aisha was told that day
everyone's going to be naked. He said oh
messenger of Allah, would they not look
at each other? He said the matter that
day is so عظیم. My friend, let me tell
you something. If the most beautiful
drop dead gorgeous woman was next to you
woman was next to you, you would not
even look. That is not your concern. On
a day like this where we're going to be
taken to account, the first thing you're
going to be asked on yawm al-qiyamah is
your salah. Yes?
How is it that so casually in Eid? Is
this I don't understand the logic. You
had a whole day a month of Ramadan
fasting trying to get close to Allah
subhanallah wa ta'ala. Which person
which possession How how possessed could
you be that you celebrate it with haram?
I don't understand. Ramadan is a month
for you to be like whatever sins I can
abstain from in sharia before I can do
it in a month, I can do it in a year.
Allah subhanallah wa ta'ala has blessed
you with Ramadan. And wallahi
wallahi, if the one that doesn't take
heed of Ramadan wallahi my dear brothers
and sisters, what do you want? You want
death to take you? You want to enter the
grave? You want the angels to come and
ask you questions that you cannot answer
and then get punished? What do you want?
Is this what you want that and
afterwards you're going to come and say
oh I wish I could go back. It's too
late. When this matter is closed, it's
closed. So what I'm saying is that
to our dear youth, please when you're
driving
you should not be driving recklessly.
Number two, under the influence?
Subhanallah, do you think on yawm
al-qiyamah you can have an excuse? The
government here, the police will not
give you excuse for oh
whatever I was doing whatever it is for
that matter. You'll get done.
On yawm al-qiyamah brothers and sisters,
you are going to be answering Allah
subhanallah wa ta'ala. Just remember
man, your heart beats man. Allah is the
one who makes your heart beat. Do you
not give him a little thanks?
Gratitude?
Please and I ask Allah subhanallah wa
ta'ala to
ask the brother and whoever's involved
in etc. crossed boundaries to repent
inshallah. And I ask our young brothers
and sisters to be very careful. It is
not worth losing the hereafter for a
glimpse or a moment of excitement or
whatever it is inshallah. May Allah
subhanallah wa ta'ala protect you guys.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.